[Music]
get ready to totally lose yours because
two music icons just took the stage
together and it was legendary ariana
grande dropped in as a surprise guest
during Barbra Streisand's concert at the
United Center in Chicago Tuesday night
where they performed babs famous duet no
more tears enough is enough with Ari
taking on the part originally sung by
Donna Summer
[Music]
are erupt a black suit like a boss which
coordinated with Barbara's all-black
ensemble and if that weren't epic enough
the two freaking held hands while they
brought down the house
I can't even it's too good
Bab shared a snap of her and Arianna
standing side by side in the green room
before the show she captioned the pic
quote secrets out Thank You Arianna
Grande
well Arianna did what we would all do
and fangirls fangirls heart she
commented on the post I'm sobbing love
you so much I can't get over this it's
just the most special and cherished
experience ever thank you it was like so
crazy but if you don't post it on your
own gram did it really happen No so the
26 year old shared the same pic only in
black and white writing cherishing this
moment forever it's just fascinating
Arianna shared several clips of the
concert on her instace story just watch
re singing those words back at Barbara
[Music]
oh and nothing says I'm freaking the
hell out like that little leg movement
right there I'm freaking out I'm
freaking out anyway
in case it wasn't clear that the pop
star was having the time of her life she
wrote the best night of my life
on this clip the performance came one
day after the 77 year old tease the
possibility of a collab by sharing this
semi cryptic snap on Instagram a
close-up of her manicured hands next to
our ease which fans recognized because
of her signature finger tats Babs
captioned the shot quote made a new
friend
I am shook this is just too much talent
on one stage and I can't deal but of
course we'll always be here to bring you
all the big ariana grande news so keep
it locked right here on e t until next
time I'm Holly Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]